Calvin I actually have it in my notes
that you came back in from a moose hunt
just to do this interview is that right
yeah so yesterday I woke up like on the
side of a river in the Canadian
wilderness and tomorrow morning I'm
probably gonna wake up in a tent on the
side of the river in the Canadian
building say hi wow were you do you do
you hunt do you hunt the the fierce
moose yes I do now I will say there's
like there's like you know shitty
Hunters out there that just try to get
like you know a rhinoceros on their wall
or whatever that's not what we do we do
it the carrot like respectful way and
it's about feeding your family and
culture what's your weapon when you hunt
a rifle is it cool to use a grenade I
don't know I mean it's not it's cool I'd
like to blow up you would not last I
would if I saw a moose I'd be like you
know they're a grenade and I would throw
it fire them all yeah and then you just
see antler antlers raining down uh
they're on antlers yes there are Giants
have antlers oh sorry Sona I didn't mean
to uh Sona is really up on Wildlife I'm
sorry oh yeah because you're an expert
on Wildlife the fierce moose I've
battled the moose in my day you're the
one who asked if moose have antlers
everyone knows they do you're bumming my
Portage okay just let's chill out all
right well that's that's very cool I
would love to go moose hunting with you
because yeah I'd be a fun guy to have
along I'm a chipper chappy
bring you down I feel like and
respectfully coming I feel like oh this
isn't gonna we all know this isn't going
well I love it respectfully okay
thankfully I feel like camping with you
would be intolerable yes
just say it I can take it say you should
try podcasting yeah you just don't take
anything seriously like everything would
just be a joke you wouldn't be done he'd
be making fun of everybody yeah
yeah so far you've got everything right
but I think that leads up to a fun time
what's the problem with everything you
just listed as long as someone else is
keeping us alive providing food and
doing all the work I think I'm just a
lot of fun to have along hey man Sony
you want to go camping sometimes yeah
Matt will be much more useful to you
than I will but that's not true I think
you will you I think you're okay so so
here here's what I think though here's
what I think yes inside you that there's
an animalistic version of you there is
it's gonna take being like pushed up
against the wall like you know a plane
crash in the wilderness where you have
to fend for yourself yeah something was
like crack I mean you've seen it Sona
right you've been around me when the
chips are down I have uh when you've
gotten rugged well I didn't say rugged
but I when pushed to the edge uh yes I
have Viking like abilities I think
kelvin's saying though like the key
there is something snaps and you become
feral yeah you go off into the woods and
you come back blood thirsty wearing a
loin cloth nothing else yeah yeah and
it's not even in the right place I I
think I should go on the show naked and
afraid yeah
um yeah oh no you don't think so just
watch it I'd watch it yeah I just I
think the clown part of you would
overtake the like serve I need to
survive part of you I think you would
die joking yes I would I do think that I
I know seriously I would I think that is
a problem I think I'm an evolutionary
dead end
I think I'm Not Meant To Survive because
DNA because when the chips really got
down Calvin and we were both trapped
there and we were starving you would
finally reach deep down into your proud
Heritage your dead Heritage and you
would go out and you would make
something happen and I would take little
pieces of rocks and twigs and create a
scenario a silly scenario
and I would um have the rock be sort of
passive aggressive to The Twig and The
Twig hit the rock and I'd be giggling as
I died but the animals around me would
be amused
if it were you and you would make jokes
with it and then you would you would die
right you'd find my skeleton later on
but you'd see that there was a I had a
grinning smile you know because I had
giggled my way into the Afterlife you
would be dead as a skeleton and then
there'd be a rubber chicken skeleton
next to you yeah you know for when
Society collapses which you know who
knows when that could happen two weeks
to always be prepared who your crew is
yeah you're gonna disappear in the woods
with and so I feel very confident that
when that happens I can just wander but
like I feel like all y'all in LA are
pretty flocked we are oh oh yeah Calvin
do you ever listen to the podcast when
you're in the wilderness like you're way
out there on your own and clearly you
you must be a fan if you've reached out
to us do you do you ever when you're
just far far away in the beauty of
nature
listen to the podcast
no
I see did you want him to say yes I did
wasn't it nice that he unplugs and he
goes out there and appreciates no he
listens to other podcasts if you could
if you could tell me that you just
listened to the ads that would help me a
lot with oh yeah the ads for sure there
you go okay great all right I'm doing
that Adam Sachs is Happy I've listened
to every single episode oh great oh good
yeah just not in the woods and and
actually so like as a dinner kid growing
up I was such a huge fan of your show
but it would be you know all the
celebrities who appear on the show they
would never be people like me okay like
indigenous folks and so it's like it's
dude honor to be able to be here and
just be able to talk to you to be like
yeah like we're like inserting more
indigeneity into the world Kelvin the
honor is ours seriously I seriously
would love to come and and check out
your neck of the woods and walk around
with you that'd be really fun yeah my
goal is as long as we brought 900 pounds
of food with us yeah McDonald's if Gorly
followed us whirly followed right behind
us as we were trekking in a Chevy
Suburban that was just packed with ring
dings miodles energy drinks
um you know then we and and laptops then
I'm fine